Film Courage: Why is storytelling important
to you?
Joe Wilson, Writer/Director/Comedian/Photographer:
I guess I feel like to some degree it’s
a service…not like a car repair service
but you are in service to storytelling whether
it’s nobody starts and makes money or few
people do so if you’re telling stories then
it’s because you want to you’re spending
time with these characters and building this
world most of the time without anyone watching,
without anyone seeing and so you’re alone
with it but you’re making it to give to
other people so it’s a service, you are
at the service of the reader, the audience,
whoever is experiencing whatever you’re
making and whatever medium or media as the
case may be.
So I guess it’s important to me because
I feel like I’m helping a little bit?
Film Courage: For what?
What are you helping?
Joe: Stories give people somewhere to go away
from all this stuff to suspend their disbelief
to go hang out with a hitman who is a vampire
and drives around and gets people [Joe’s
web series VAMPIRE MOB].
That is an escape for people it is somewhere
to go with a suspension of disbelief.
Stories have been around since the beginning
of time because that’s what we all sat around
and did because it was really crappy wi-fi
when you’re a caveman so people were telling
stories and drawing stuff.
Then it’s just verbal, one generation telling
the next generation, telling the next generation
until you start writing that stuff down.
Stories are…man you can get people hurt
with stories, you can change people’s lives
with stories, you can…a whole country can
believe a story and do really bad things.
Film Courage: And have been done.
Joe: Yes, storytelling is really powerful.
That suspension of disbelief thing, the real
world uses it all the time, it’s not just
for storytellers.
Film Courage: What about if a writers says
storytelling for me is a selfish motive, a
selfish endeavor and I make no apologies for
it.
I love creating other worlds, it doesn’t
even mean I need people to love the story,
I just love to be…
Joe: Yeah…that sounds fantastic but that
storyteller…the whole not needing any one
thing than no one’s gonna see your stuff
man.
You’re just going to type and like “I’m
just going to fill up hard drives with stories
because I love it so much and I’m so great!”
Hmm…really?
Are you just waiting until you pass and someone
is going to publish all of your stuff and…no.
I think that person is…maybe if that’s
what it takes for them to be able to write,
great.
But the reality is if no one sees it then
- like screenplays are maps for movies, they
are not meant to be read, they are meant to
be made.
So all the movies that I’ve written so far
have not been made and will not be made and
that’s okay.
Some of them are crappy, a couple of them
I’m probably going to adapt into books because
they were fun to write them and they would
be more fun as a book and I wouldn’t have
to deal with trying to get it done.
Also, if I was to make a movie it would be
indie and I know what it’s like to be crushed
by production.
I would never make a movie at this point just
because I can’t do anything else when I’m
making a movie.
I know people have made movies, it’s two
years pretty much at least all the time, full
time and it’s really expensive and it takes
a lot of people and it takes a lot of people
who have to stay with the project.
It’s really hard to keep people motivated
when they’re not making a lot of money and
most likely I am making a movie where they’re
not making a lot of money.
Then after I have that movie made then I have
to get people to watch it and all of that
seems like too much to do for me for the amount
of time I’ve got left on the planet and
for what else I think I can achieve in the
same amount of time and also I could make
a crappy movie so I’d hate to spend two
years making crap.
Question for the viewers:
Have you felt this way?
What self-talk do you use to keep pushing
forward?